This DNews episode is brought to you by Domain
dot com!
You follow the news, right?
So, I probably DON'T need to tell you that
there's been an outbreak of the measles linked
to a certain Mouse-centered park system.
I don't know about you but when I hear outbreak
of the measles, I start thinking back to the
17th century, and colonial America, but since
the virus was identified in the nineteen-teens
and a vaccination was created in the late
50s; the measles has been a relatively easy
disease to control.
In fact, our regional strain of the measles
was eliminated from the US as of 2000, but
it's still fairly common in Europe, Asia,
Africa and the Pacific.
In 2014, though, there were a record number
of measles cases in the U.S.
The CDC says there were 644 cases in 27 states
last year; and that a majority of those people
of the infected were unvaccinated.
Makes sense.
Herd immunity can only protect you for so
long people.
2015 has already had 59 cases, from a single
Disneyland exposure -- including five employees
of the parks.
The measles is REALLY contagious.
It was first described in some way by Persian
physicians in the year 900.
It causes a rash all over your body, swelling,
fever, a cough and little spots inside the
cheeks called Koplik spots.
It's deadly to young children and is one of
the leading causes for children worldwide.
Measles, or rubeola is a virus, and there
is no cure.
It spreads by flying into the air during a
cough or sneeze or piggybacking on the sharing
of food or drinks.
If you had the measles and you're watching
this, CONGRATULATIONS!
Tell us about history Nana and PopPop!!
Most people born before 1957 have had the
measles; so I just want to make them feel
included.
The reason the cutoff is 1957 -- is because
in 1958** a vaccine went into wide use and
boom.
Measles infections dropped precipitously.
Since then, the WHO has attempted to vaccinate
children worldwide, which likely saved hundreds
of thousands of lives.
Since 2000 they've dropped cases 75% worldwide
thanks to the MMR vaccine.
The vaccine for the measles is part of the
MMR vaccine; which stands for measles-mumps
and rubella.
Measles is the worst, but the mumps causes
a swelling of the parotid glands giving the
face a hamster look; sounds cute, but it's
not cute.
It's painful and highly contagious.
It can also caught inflammation of the testis,
ovary, pancreas, or meninges.
Rubella is also known as the german measles,
and it's like the measles, but far milder.
Luckily, the MMR vaccine is one of the most
effective in the world.
With only two doses, 97-percent of human immune
systems create enough antibodies to fight
off any measles it may come in contact with.
Usually, the first comes near birth, and the
second a few years later to make sure the
immunity is solid.
Measles sounds crappy, what with the rashes
and diarrhea, but it can also cause permanent
damage to the lungs or the brain.
It's also connected to seizures and meningitis!
This strange resurgence of measles we're hearing
about in the news, is likely because of the
recent trend against vaccination.
Only six of the infected had the MMR shot,
the rest did not… which jives with the high
protection rate; according to Wired and the
CDC.
If people stop getting the MMR vaccine, they
become happy little dumpsters for the diseases
which can't take hold anywhere else.
As we only eliminated the endemic measles,
unvaccinated Americans travelling abroad are
still able to contract measles where it has
not been eliminated and transport it to areas
where it has before they show symptoms.
Even perfect immunity isn't entirely safe,
remember, it's only 97-percent effective.
So this is where personal choices for vaccination
become problematic.
It might be a personal choice to be an anti-vaxxer,
but this choice can harm other people, even
those who DID get vaccinated.